الصحه العالميه وصفته بالفتاك فثمانيه
وثمانون بالمئه من المصابين به يموتون انه
فيروس مارب عاد الحديث حول هذا الفيروس
الذي يوصف بالقاتل بعد تفشيل ملحوظ في
غينيا الاستوائيه وتنزانيا ودعوات دول عده
كالسعوديه وعمان لرعاياها الى تجنب السفر
للدولتين الافريقتين الا للضروره القصوى
لكن ما هي خطوره هذا الفيروس هيئه الصحه
العامه بالسعوديه اوضحت ان مارج مرض يصيب
الانسان وتكون حضانه الفيروس فيه ما بين
يومين الى 21 يوما بعد التعرض للعدوى
اعراض الاصابه به تبدا بفقدان الشهيه
والصداع الشديد وتصل حتى خروج الدم من
الفم او الانف او العين او اي مكان اخر
يجرح فيه الجلد اما عن كيفيه انتقاله الى
الانسان فقد تكون من حيوان مصاب بعد
ملامسه دمه او عبر الت المباشر معه او
افرازاته او السوائل الاخرى من جسده كما
ينتقل بين البشر اذا ما تمت ملامسه سوائل
شخص مصاب بشكل مباشر او حتى غير مباشر عبر
لمس فراشه وملابسه والمعدات الطبيه التي
قد تستخدم في علاجه لكن كيف يمكن تجنب
الاصابه به يكون ذلك عبر تجنب السفر
للمناطق الموبوءه وبغسل اليدين باستمرار
ما عدم لمس الحيوانات النافقه اما في حاله
المخالطه او العوده من منطقه موبوءه
فماسولوه الصحه ينصحون بالعزل الذاتي اولا
وفي حال ظهور الاعراض يجب تبليغ السلطات